buy a car that you can afford in cash
and if you can't afford a car in cash
save up money to afford a car here's why
you should never buy or lease a car we
should do instead is buy a car in cash
drive into the ground and still be able
to sell it for five thousand dollars two
years later and drive it for free you
already have insurance and gas you don't
need anything else you can find a car
for 10 grand in every city in America
and a used car lot or just on Craigslist
those cars are available every day and
so anyone even on minimum wage can save
enough money to get that car look at
something that's 10 plus years old from
a reputable maker and you can search
online for the ones that have the lowest
repair cost per mile literally the only
reason to have a nice car is for
appearances I had a million dollars in
my bank account and I still had a Prius
with a dent in the side door and a crack
in the windshield and when I pulled up
to an event someone was like I thought
you were supposed to be rich and I said
you should look at my bank account not
my car